yes this is what you look like and what
you sound like after you have been to an
Internet convention for a weekend hi
guys my name is grace Helbig if you did
not know now you know you can read the
title of this video I hope can't I'm
rooting for you it's time for June
favorites here are some of the things
that I have enjoyed slightly more than
other things this month first yeah yes
this is or no need what's up what
caution keep from heat or flame or if
it's a cold flame this is product name
is not on the bottle this is a Lancome
lip thing maybe this is Lancome teaching
me that I shouldn't be so dependent on
things for information I should start
storing up in here except up here the
drawers are full
it's made of France if that helps narrow
it down Estee talks about this Estee is
a really wonderful beauty guru type of
wonderful person on YouTube she
mentioned this lip product in one of her
favorites videos and she talked very
lovingly about the applicator which I'll
show you look at this everything in me
wants to say that this applicator looks
like a micropenis but i won't say that
it's this spongy applicator that she
kept talking about how satisfying it
felt squishing it on your lips it is
actually very satisfying I have the
color on right now today it's a very
sheer color and also for those of you
that are like me that eat everything off
of your lips without intention it
doesn't last long you will have to
reapply which is really fun because this
feels really nice to do you'll see that
the theme of all of my favorites this
month
it veers towards more of the quirk and
experiential part of the product rather
than the other parts of the product yes
okay you get me I like this
next yeah you see it yeah say yeah yeah
say yeah this goes against everything I
just said I love this product this is a
very very good lip product this is from
Tarte and it's called TARDIS lip paint
and this is in the color cray-cray
appropriate that you felt art because
that name makes my face feel like I just
ate something sour this lip color I wore
a lot at VidCon over the weekend it's a
very sort of orangey red lip color and
it just stays on your lips it's like
activist that chains himself to a tree
and your lips are the Amazon rainforest
like that they're not going anywhere and
it's super simple packaging a really
easy tube to carry around with you easy
to reapply I liked it very much
etc etc etc max yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
see ya this is Kat Von D's locket
foundation and this is one part work and
two parts actual product is amazing most
of this I got in the same order from
sephora.com recently and I read the
reviews of this foundation and it was
exactly what I was looking for it's a
heavy coverage foundation and it's
called Lockett foundation for a reason
because this is like a chastity belt on
your face like no one it's going to push
with your face at all also it's got this
little cap thing on it and when you pop
that off aha there's the dispenser
that's cute
it's like a process but getting it back
on and of is annoying
it might mix there we go did it like I
said a word that's a big con and it
really lasted me all day and it hardly
got oily or needed to be touched up so
this was fantastic next yes yes he is
yeah yes oh yeah this is benefits kaboom
no it's not that this is benefits to
brow because quark cream gel brow color
with brush and look you might be looking
at this product and be like with brush
where's the brush welcome to the pork
part of the product oh my god there's a
brush snap it into the top and then oh
my god but also like thank god there's a
brush in this lid because otherwise if
this
but other than the pure novelty of this
product the product actually lasted all
day and I thought did a really great job
I might have gotten a slightly darker
color than I should have but that's my
fault not theirs don't take it out on
them take it out on me by subscribing to
my youtube channel next yeah yeah yeah
this is a face product for your face
this is a night serum and here's the
thing it's from a brand called drunk
elephant and I'm going to be very honest
with you that is the only reason I
bought it because of the name because I
am an idiot I found this product a few
months ago and I've waited to see if it
made my skin mutate into something awful
before putting it in a favorites video I
read a bunch of reviews and the reviews
are really mixed a lot of people had a
really wonderful thing to say and a lot
of people had not so wonderful things to
say so I decided to try it TLC Fram
booze glycolic night serum refined and
regenerate it seemed to be the product
that most people had the best results
with whatever it's called drunk elephant
it was the fun part of it but I got this
it took me about solid two minutes to
figure out how to get to the product
there's a little thing on top I kept
clicking this I kept pulling this
nothing what's happening and surprise
here's how you do it BAM and it squirts
out right there work out the butthole
it's hard to recommend skincare because
everyone's skin is different so you
really have to experiment I have
combination skin it's very down the
middle it's not exceptionally dry it's
not exceptionally oily it doesn't break
out super easily but it does break out
around the time that I'm experiencing
the difficulty of the female experience
macaroon so I'm lucky enough to not have
a very extreme sensitive skin type in
either direction and I can say that this
product has worked really well it makes
me feel like my skin is healthier feels
a little tighter feels a little cleaner
to put it on before I go to sleep I
leave it on all night I wash my face in
the morning and I do this a bunch just
for stress yeah take this to the naked
eye looks like a Hawaiian
festive shirt but if you follow me on
snapchat you know that this is part of a
costume
I found this shirt at Party City when I
was shopping for props for another video
I thought this was a great shirt for
life and I bought it and I wore it my
style has become vacation dad and I'm I
have mo k with I got this shirt recently
in the boys section of a Disney Store
down at Disneyland so yeah this is fun
and cute and vacation dad is my favorite
look for the month
next yeah if they say at work doesn't
stop this is a clutch that I got from
Zara I'm sure that you could make
something very similar to this yourself
on my blog surprise I have a blog did a
whole blog post about how you can take
denim shorts and add a bunch of patches
to them and make them fun summer denim
shorts
I think this clutch was something in the
range of 20 to 30 ish dollars but you
could probably make it free for cheaper
if you got just the black little clutch
and put some catches on it I like these
eyeballs looking at this flying heart
like shouldn't you be in a body
somewhere helping keep it alive and also
this area here that was really
interesting because this looks like it's
like someone mmm like brown the diarrhea
explosion but maybe this is a good idea
next you can't see it you can't see it
here but you can see it if you're gonna
do 30 movie.com that's right the dirty
30 movie official trailer is out we
debuted at VidCon and it is now
available for everyone to watch at
greater clarity movie comm please go
check it out here's a little snippet
let's see what you got whoa also
released the release day which is summer
23rd Wow we're gonna do it a limited
theatrical release as well as a digital
download so make sure you're very
clearly movie calm to watch the trailer
and to find out all of the wonderful
information surrounding the film and
that is it that is it that is it that is
and that's it for my June favorites I
hope that you guys enjoy this video if
you did let me know leave some comments
down below what have been the things
that you have been liking this month
other than the staccato of my speech and
don't forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel because that something
just so kind of you other than that I
don't know freeze